today we're talking about dying light 2
getting delayed again how you can
finally expand your ps5 storage starting
tomorrow as well as an xbox update that
makes it just a little bit easier to
stream your games on pc my name is
devonte chisholm and you're watching
game spot news
let's kick this one off with some delay
news because just when i thought q1 2022
couldn't get more crowded dying light to
hopped out of a dark corner and told me
i was wrong the zombie title will now
launch february 4th 2022
instead of december of this year
according to a statement from the game's
developer techland dying light 2 is
complete and the team is now play
testing it however due to the ambitious
nature of the game the studio determined
that it needed more time to focus on
polish and optimization to quote bring
the game to the level we envision teclam
went on to say it will invite press and
content creators to play the game and
share their thoughts soon the studio
concluded by saying it will have quote
some exciting news to reveal later this
month dying light 2 now has a lot of
friends to hang out with in its new
release month there's horizon forbidden
west sifu saints row and destiny 2's
witch queen expansion needless to say
plenty of wallets out there are going to
need medical attention come next year
switching gears to game of the year
contender death loop following a day of
praise for the game the legendary hideo
kojima took to twitter to give his
thoughts as well kojima said quote death
loop it's a time loop game with an
interesting system i want to play it but
it's an fps and i'll probably get 3d
sick hmm
he continued to quote i've always gotten
sick even though i was in the gymnastics
team on field trips i sat at the front
of the bus i get sick on the swings at
amusement parks i can't go on the
teacups viking rides flying carpets
octopus rides or anything that's spun
roller coasters are fine i happen to be
in a very similar boat to kojima as i
can not handle any spinning rides
luckily i can play fps games so i will
be able to enjoy death lube later a game
that our very own timur hussein gave a
10 out of 10. and if you want to know
why death loop is good enough to be
gamespot's 20th perfect score then make
sure you go check out his review right
after this video
but all right let's talk about some
console updates now first up is
playstation because starting tomorrow
after a two month long firmware test ps5
users will be able to expand their
console storage with an nvme m.2 ssd
instead of something proprietary like
microsoft's official expansion option
unless of course you're down for trying
the modded version that one xbox user
detailed in a blog post you can check
out yesterday's news video for more on
that tomorrow's playstation 5 system
update will also bring the console's 3d
audio tech from headsets to built-in tv
speakers meanwhile users of sony's pulse
3d wireless headset will receive access
to an equalizer as part of the update
some other quality of life changes
include the ability to customize the
control center by rearranging or hiding
certain buttons sending messages from
the game base and see more details at a
glance about your own games in the game
library for more info on this update
make sure to visit gamespot.com
and over on the microsoft side of things
windows pcs are getting an update to the
xbox app that introduces functionality
allowing users to stream console games
from their home console or the cloud
this functionality is live now for game
pass ultimate subscribers in 22
countries before this the xbox cloud
gaming service worked on phones tablets
and pcs through the browser but now it's
baked directly into the xbox app and as
for streaming games from your home
console microsoft says this is quote
essentially a way to mirror your console
gaming experience on another screen this
happens through the xbox remote play
feature inside the xbox app for windows
10 pcs
and now i want you to hit the comment
section and let me know your preferred
way to play is it streaming from the
cloud streaming from a console or just
directly on that console
see you later
[Music]
you